according to the attack on Titan website
it looks like part three of the final
season is not going to have weekly
episodes but instead the remaining
content will be split into two movies on
the 3rd of March we'll get the first
movie which is a one hour long special
episode that will continue where part
two left off and then later in the year
we'll get the second special which could
be even longer these two long episodes
will adapt the remaining content left in
the manga but I don't think anyone was
expecting it to be released in this
format if you want my full thoughts on
the situation click on the link to my
Channel Down Below where I explain
everything you need to know about part 3
and other Attack on Titan news